all right good morning good people of
the Internet at least this morning here
in the West Coast 8:45 a.m. Pacific
11:45 a.m. Eastern and later if you're
more that way towards Europe and
Australian stuff its later in the day
you're in the future
I'm lagging behind but I'm gonna do the
best I can to give you some sensible
information okay we're in like week six
a lockdown things seem to be getting a
little bit weird we're gonna talk about
that I really want to focus on the
upcoming election which you know we're
supposed to have an election everything
that led up to the election the debates
the conversation the political partisan
bickering all of it seems largely almost
completely actually irrelevant at this
point which is kind of weird and the
Democrats have decided to just go in
with Biden which is depressing and
confusing and many other adjectives that
Biden wouldn't be able to come up with
themselves we'll get to that just a sec
just want to do a little clerical stuff
and maybe Clyde will join us he is at my
feet right now we'll see if Clyde wants
to get up here at some point so real
quick this is this is a huge week for us
I would say that basically this week and
next week probably the the two biggest
weeks of my career my book don't burn
this book comes out next Tuesday I
finished writing this thing last July we
edited it in the fall up until about
Thanksgiving and then we basically been
sitting on it there was a huge meeting
with penguin Random House and all the
people about delaying the book further
because of Corona and tons of books got
delayed and some books got canceled and
all sorts of stuff but I was like no
we've got to get it out get it out now I
just believe in moving forward moving
forward you can't delay because what if
this rolls into May into June into July
and more than anything else I'm just
super proud that the ideas that I
present in these pages are actually more
relevant now because of Corona when I
talk about states rights that suddenly
everyone's talking about it's a huge
part of this book I talk about how the
founders set up this system so that the
states were mostly supposed to govern
themselves and then the federal
government can do a little bit what I
talked about related to guns and borders
and China and a whole bunch other stuff
it's all in here and all relevant and I
obviously wrote this way before Corona
it comes out next Tuesday and here's the
deal people if you go to don't burn this
book
komm you can pre-order it from Amazon or
Barnes & Noble or your local book store
you're gonna get a confirmation code and
then if you go to Ruben report.com slash
pre-sale you enter that code right in
there and we will take you to an
hour-long video that we shot this
weekend with my husband David
interviewing me we put up a little
teaser of it on the channel already that
you can see we told a story about
meeting Donald Trump at mar-a-lago back
in December if you haven't seen it yet
you should watch it it's the first time
we've really talked about it publicly
and it was it was pretty wild I had some
one-on-one time with the president David
had some one-on-one time with the first
lady and some funny stuff happened and
just you'll want to check it out and
that's just a tiny portion of the
hour-long interview David talks to me
about a lot of a lot of personal stuff
and you get to meet him and hear about
his life and what it was like to build
the Reuben report together and yes both
of our names are David and people can't
believe it and all that good stuff
one more thing just a reminder to
subscribe to this channel click that
bell and maybe you'll get our videos
that would be very exciting and don't
forget it there go over to Reuben
report.com slash presale and you will
get that exclusive video and the book
comes out next Tuesday okay so what do I
want to talk about today well first off
before we get to the election stuff
specifically there was a video that was
going kind of viral as the kids say
Twitter yesterday which was YouTube CEO
Susan Wojcicki she was on reliable
sources with brian Stelter now as I
always say the show should be called
unreliable sources and then it would
make a lot more sense but there he was
Humpty Dumpty himself Stelter sitting
there asking Susan about misinformation
on YouTube this is obviously a topic
that I care a lot about because I am
broadcasting this on YouTube and she
said something interesting she well she
said several interesting things but
there was one quote in particular
related to misinformation and what
videos they allow up and what videos
they take down and she specifically said
that they will censor people the quote
actually was anything that would go
against the World Health Organization
recommendations would be a violation of
our policy that means the videos can be
taken down and we know at that point you
know if that leads to a strike on your
channel suddenly you can't
live stream you get three strikes your
channels gone we know that they've just
deleted channels just like that if they
want to so I don't want to get into the
whole thing about big tech I think you
guys know my feelings about big tech and
sadly what has happened here is for the
last two years while many of us talked
about big tech then Corona happened and
we all got more in bed with big tech
right it's the only way we can
communicate right now except for locals
calm by the way which is my tech company
that built Rubin report calm and we're
adding some huge game changing people
over the next couple weeks and there's a
lot a lot of good going on there but I
don't mention it to promote locals I
mention it because the idea that just
because the world health organization
says something and that if you
contradict that on YouTube they're gonna
take your video down and potentially
potentially ban you block your you know
block your channel suspend you in the
rest of it just because the World Health
Organization says something doesn't mean
it's right I'm not some tin foil
conspiracy theorist but we know that the
World Health Organization has made
mistakes along the way about telling
people not to wear masks and the rest of
it but even if they had it even if they
were a perfect system which doesn't even
exist but even if they were why would we
want to stop anyone from saying anything
against what they order and I think
without getting too far into the
psychology of this this really explains
what the what the authoritarian brain is
the authoritarian brain loves
authoritarianism so they just love when
organizations or governments or giant
institutions just say something and they
feel that that in and of itself makes it
authoritarianism
an authoritarian voice and it's not is
that a word I don't know but this is a
really dangerous thing of course we
should be able to criticize the w-h-o of
course we should be able to say you know
someone that there could be a youtuber
there could be a scientist on YouTube
that is looking at the same data that
the w-h-o is looking at and may have a
different feeling why why should that
video not be out there now it's
interesting that she's even saying it so
upfront because you know the fact that
she could just suppress the videos and
not even say it is interesting I will
say one other thing on this and I want
to talk about the election I met Susan
majeski at the YouTube office you may
remember about a year and a half ago
there was a leaker
Google at YouTube who specifically said
that Dave Rubin and Tim Poole and a
couple other guys were amongst the
channels that YouTube was suppressing
and finally it blew up enough that Susan
sort of had to meet with me Shh it was
clear that she didn't want meet with me
I think she also met with ben shapiro
and a couple other people I took a
picture outside YouTube and the first
thing that happened when I walked in the
PR people were like oh you had to take
that picture didn't you and it was just
like very clear that I'm not like there
and whatever else and you know I sat
there with her and the the PR people and
maybe there was a lawyer there I'm not
even sure who the other person was and I
have nothing against these people
I don't again I'm not a crazy conspiracy
theorist she did agree to do my show so
I've emailed her and DM her and tweeted
at her she's not calling up I would love
to have that conversation but we had a
full off-the-record conversation and I
won't I won't break that trust but I
just mentioned all of this because as
Corona keeps us in the houses and and
whatever happens after this big tech is
now looming larger than ever before and
we should be aware of that so Susan you
were welcome to come on the show I will
treat you with the exact same respect I
treat everybody else and that's that
okay let's talk about the election so
there's a lot going on right now in case
you didn't know that and part of it
right now is that we have this election
in November that is not many months away
right that's like six months away barely
now a lots gonna change by the time we
get to November so it's a little hard to
play the prediction game right now but
let's all right quickly let's just talk
about Trump and and Biden I think
Trump's positioning right now short of
an absolute economic collapse or short
of an economy that just cannot open I
think his position is basically pretty
good right he's trying to give the power
back to the states which I think is the
right thing and then figure out where
the federal government can do things you
can argue that he didn't do this fast
enough or this that or the other thing
that's all completely legit but I think
his basic premise of we have to be
harder on China and he had the China ban
I think he's been pushing the idea of
states rights I think people aren't
understanding that I think he gets wins
on things like the
an amendment now because people are
realizing they have to defend themselves
and I think people are thinking about
government tyranny a little bit
different which is sort of interesting
because all of these lefties that were
screaming that Trump is Hitler for the
last four years which is insane
suddenly you're going oh I maybe do have
to defend myself against the government
so I think there's a lot of people
waking up to all sorts of stuff I saw a
guy who's a hugely and that doesn't
matter who it is some of them friendly
with but he's a he's a blue check
Twitter person who's got you know
probably a million followers who's a
lefty progressive the whole thing I text
him all the time and I try to explain to
him why he's wrong about everything we
the healthy basically a healthy back and
forth I would say and he was suddenly
texting about we need to lower taxes now
because people need more money and it's
like yeah most of these most of the
things that I lay out in this book that
are common sense principles there's
nothing controversial in this book it's
it's common sense but common sense is
now controversial but I love seeing that
suddenly lefties are going oh maybe the
second amendment does matter maybe
states rights do matter maybe we should
lower taxes like there's a lot of
interesting things that I think play
well my point is that plays well to sort
of the Republican or conservative base
now that look the issue with Biden I've
said it a million times this guy does
not have the mental acumen to do it we
know that the DNC is just dragging him
there right like in many ways the DNC
has to be thrilled that they can sort of
hide him although he keeps doing these
video chats that are pretty awful and he
keeps looking down at his notes and he's
still he's still for that's what he's
saying and it's pretty depressing but
they're just kind of dragging him there
I do I will throw out one minor
conspiracy theory here this is something
I've been thinking about a little bit
remember that Bloomberg guy I don't know
what happened to him where you know he
put how much money did he put into five
hundred million into his election bid
does he put any into any Crona anything
well what if this this is a little bit
of a conspiracy theory what if Bloomberg
got in for those three pathetic weeks
only because at that point Biden was the
front-runner and they knew that
everybody was going to have to go after
Biden and take him out and they got
Bloomberg and just to offer Biden cover
for a little while to get the nomination
no it sounds like a conspiracy theory
but I actually don't think it's probably
that far from the truth in any event the
DNC is sort of coalesced around him and
he's going to be the nominee but again
if you are voting for Joe Biden who I do
not think is a bad man
and you could probably find tweets of
mine from 2008 if I was even on Twitter
but there was some public something if
not Twitter that I was writing on a blog
or something when he was running against
Barack Obama as the Democratic nominee
he ran in the in the primary I liked him
I liked Biden so this is not anti Biden
I don't really like him anymore
obviously I've changed politically in
these twelve years but the point is that
everyone knows that that be Obama video
you probably saw the Obama video
endorsing Biden and it's like first off
watching Obama o Muhammad otally
irrelevant now like where is the base
that loves Obama I mean I guess a few of
them are on MSNBC but where are the
young people that love Obama they s they
like a OC god bless them so I just think
they're gonna drag this guy there but
you just have to know that if you're
voting for Joe Biden you're voting for
his vice president and that really
what's so damaging about that is people
already know that the DNC is corrupt and
they rigged it against Bernie last time
and that Donna Brazile who is the head
of the DNC at one point was handing
questions to Hillary and then she was a
CNN anchor we know about this deep
corruption and if they if they really do
this where they just dragged by it in
there knowing that this really is that
you make the VP president which it will
be either they're gonna get rid of him
at the last second right before the
nomination where they do it right after
or two months into the presidency some
version of that we all know it's true
it would really show that the entire
election process was was fraudulent
really that they just had a plan and
they made that plan work and Bernie by
the way will will be totally destroyed
in this of course which is which is
exactly what he deserves
you know he's backed up the corporatist
candidate last time Hillary and he's
doing it again this time and now the
base will just have to destroy the old
socialist so I kind of dig that thing
but anyway it's a big mess but but
relative to the election with corona and
everything else we don't know when this
is ending states are gonna have
different things right so I'm stuck here
in the People's Republic of California
at least for now and it sounds like
California we've got a progressive
governor and a ridiculous progressive
mayor in this city New York City has de
Blasio I mean there Christ if you pray
now is the time certain places are going
to have a much harder time opening up
now New York because there's a much
higher concentration of the virus and
in Queens especially I heard actually
that in Corona Queens that's a place
Corona Queens has one of the highest
rates of kovat which is pretty bizarre
but anyway in any event the idea of
these populous areas having trouble
opening up big cities having trouble
opening but if you live in Montana or
you live in Idaho or you live in
Colorado or something like that you
might it might be a little bit easier
maybe not in Denver specifically but you
know in places where people can move
around more freely and also beyond
everything else you know at some point
we have to decide it's just the
uncomfortable truth we have to decide
what kind of sickness and what level of
death we would be tolerable so that we
don't live in our homes forever that's
just a depressing truth that we all are
gonna have to confront at some point but
by the way we do that every day with
everything there are diseases out there
people get hit by cars all sorts of
terrible people get murdered I mean all
sorts of terrible things happen and we
have to weigh that risk versus the
reward of being functioning free human
beings so relating this all to the
election you know you've been seeing a
big push from Democrats now that they
want to do it all by mail and it's like
if there was ever a time not to fully
change our electoral system it's right
now it's like all of our systems are
like kind of like this they're all kind
of shaking they're all kind of weird and
the idea that we would change a system
we already know I mean look the
Democrats in the media didn't accept the
election results last time now they've
already got the excuse lined up and then
they'll push for mail-in votes and then
they'll say that didn't work and that's
not a defense of what the Republicans
might do but if anything this idea
suddenly of national voter ID I know
somehow people on the Left think that
voter ID is racist or something like
that but if the I would be okay with the
federal government saying if you're a
citizen of the United States we're going
to give you an ID that is the ID that
you have to use to vote and then we can
figure out is there a way to do that
electronically perhaps hopefully with
some sort of paper trail and everything
else but everyone can get an ID
there's nothing racist about saying
someone should have an ID how else can
we have secure elections you can just
walk into a when I voted in the
Democratic primary here in California I
didn't show anyone ID I said my name and
my address and actually my address
wasn't even matched up to my current
address because I moved a couple years
we need something that secures this I
have no problem with everyone having an
ID the idea that people can I get IDs
and that somehow his racist something
like that is bananas but that's just
sort of like mainstream progressive
think but do you believe you should have
an ID to get on a plane do you believe
you should have an ID to drive to buy a
beer or something like that like usually
therefore IDs in that regard and these
are people who love power so the idea
that this is the one thing guys that's
left up to you guys you all figure it
out
seems a little bizarre to me so I think
my general feeling would be that unless
there is an economic collapse I think
this thing sort of shakes out well for
conservatives for Republicans because I
think that's where the ideas are
tracking more correctly and
unfortunately the left has just sort of
gone off the deep end but we just we
simply don't know like there's there are
so many things up in the air and let's
not forget we could also end up in some
crazy trade war or even worse with China
you know there's a chance that we that
we have a dip in corona over the next
couple months as the weather warms up
and then people are saying it starts
again so what if you know we start
opening States and then they have to
close again like we really are in a new
world right now and I think we just
desperately need some sane honest voices
and it's like damn we just don't have
them on television and I guess it's
getting irrelevant Matt one of the
things I've been thinking lately is you
know so many of us and and I fault
myself here too we spent so much time
railing on CNN and the rest of it and
it's like if we didn't talk about CNN
nobody's watching CNN but there's a
feeling like we have to rail against it
because it's it's what is mainstream so
when Chris Cuomo you guys probably saw
this video Chris Cuomo climbs out of his
basement saying that he's been in
quarantine for weeks even though it's
known that he was out while he
supposedly had coronavirus just a week
or two before and he got into a
confrontation with a bicyclist
and it's like they present this like WWE
propaganda like dude not like a WWE skit
like it's a it's it's a CNN skit it's a
comedy skit basically he comes up the
stairs and he says I've been working out
and I'm sweating and he won't touch
anyone in his family still and it's like
CNN is is terrible it's a terrible
propaganda channel but maybe we should
just let it be maybe I should stop
railing against it we just let that let
it die I don't know it's I'm conflicted
by that because you also want to call
out misinformation where it
alright guys couple questions real quick
er man I got a roll I'm doing a ton of
press everyday right now I'm basically
in this chair pretty much all day long
got a little bit of a stiff back
actually because I'm just doing a ton of
press I shot the Ben Shapiro Sunday
special I'm the first ever to time
guests that'll be up in a couple days
I'll be on with dan dan Crenshaw and
Glenn Beck and I shot Michael Shermer
podcast and a whole bunch of other a
bunch of new podcasts that I didn't even
know exist and a bunch of radio shows
and all that stuff so there's gonna be a
massive push next week so if you're not
sick of me yet you'll be sick of me by
next week I promise you that and again
guys if you want to see the exclusive
interview with my husband David
interviewing me and we talked about
meeting Trump and what it was like is
Trump a giant homophobe find out order
don't burn this book that don't burn
this book calm or wherever you get your
books and then go to Ruben report.com
slash presale put your order
confirmation number in there and you can
watch that video okay I'll just do a
couple questions real quick chant oh do
you think the reopen protests are
effective they're effective I would say
at some level because first off I think
they're personally effective if you want
to get out there and voice your opinion
and hopefully do it responsibly and wear
a mask instead you know stand a couple
feet away from people and tell your
government that you want to be heard and
all that I think it's you're right and I
mean in many ways your duty as an
American to do it so I think they're
effective in that way I think that
showing people that you can stand up for
yourself is also important and then
watching you know I was watching like
you know these you know Jimmy Kimmel had
this ridiculous tweet about how these
people something the effect of like
these people are want us all to die and
it's like no Jimmy you elitist
millionaire no they don't want you to
Jimmy who's been in blackface by the way
Jimmy they just they just want to live
freely and go back to work and maybe not
trust the government fully that's sort
of an American thing and you know I saw
some other comedians do that sort of
stuff and I think actually the pushback
against it is even better than than
before so I think some good things are
happening so I think people just have to
responsibly do what they think is right
I'll just do two more real quick Nate
Dave any plans to continue to and stand
up once the pandemic is over in the book
finished yeah I hope to get back to it I
mean most importantly we're gonna we're
gonna get the tour going and I cannot
wait I mean I was supposed to be in New
York City this week doing a ton of press
and all that stuff and now I'm obviously
not I'm doing it all from here and then
the book tour was supposed to launch on
the 28th next week we were doing the
Gramercy Theatre in New York City and
then we were doing a countrywide tour we
will do it at some point and I will
shake your hands and all of those things
so we will do it at some point and then
yeah I'll get back to stand up after and
then oh this is this is an interesting
one chris says you mentioned on Twitter
yesterday that Tim Poole finally took
the red pill what do you consider the
red pill to be so the red pill of course
is is is a commentary or it's a moment
in the Matrix movie when Morpheus offers
neo the choice right you can take the
red pill and see reality as it is or you
can take the blue pill and just go back
to sleep live your life not knowing what
the truth is this has become a meme sort
of of the internet where it's like if
you kind of get over the factory
settings nonsense Democrats good
Republicans bad lefties like poor people
people on the right like money like all
of that nonsense Democrats are for peace
Republicans are for war all of the
things that culture sort of treats us
which by the way I talk about pretty
extensively in the book if you are over
that and you can see the world really
for what it is as uncomfortable as that
is and for the price that you will pay
right like the life that neo lives after
taking the red pill is much harder life
than he was living before and his little
cubicle just being a programmer next
thing you know he's fighting guys in
slow motion there's bullets flying
everywhere that's a lot if you want to
see the world as it is you got to start
understanding that there's some more
information out there that maybe you
were a bit brainwashed on and it's a
very uncomfortable thing and and Tim had
a tweet what was the tweet specifically
he had a tweet in effect he was it was
something to the idea of Oh somebody had
sent out a tweet saying that people that
the protesters should have to sign
waiver saying that if they get corona
that nobody should have to take care of
them there should be no health insurance
and you know that the states should have
nothing to do with it and Tim basically
wrote back and he's like alright well
then if we're gonna have health
insurance for everybody I guess if
you're fat or you smoke or you don't
exercise blah blah blah then then that
shouldn't be on the rest of us too and
that's like a
very red-billed commentary that if we're
all in this together we're gonna start
watching each other if we're all paying
for each other then why should a person
who's perfectly fit who eats well and
everything else pay for a fat smoker who
does high-risk behaviors and all sorts
other stuff like that's like a very red
pill thought once you start unfurling
some of this stuff anyway guys don't
burn this book dot-com get the book
pre-order it comes out next Tuesday I
know you will dig it I promise you will
dig it and if you order it before
Tuesday basically for the pre-sale you
can go to Reuben report comm slash
pre-sale enter your confirmation code
and you'll get an hour-long video with
me and David and we talked about
building the Reuben recording a lot of
personal stuff and all kinds of good
stuff Clyde you didn't get up once for
this thing alright guys I got a crazy
day ahead hope you're all good hope
you're safe if there's any anything you
need if you're going through something
if you lost your job whatever it is keep
us abreast of things tweet at me you can
email us contact at Reuben report com
don't forget to subscribe click that
bell and have a good day stay safe